one man is dead tonight after an
altercation at la villa vegas mobile
home park that's off east charleston and
mohave that is where we find madison
kimbrough live tonight with the latest
details on this so madison what have you
learned
yeah the shooting happened around 1 p.m
this afternoon right here at this
trailer park we're going to zoom in so
you can kind of see the area that we're
talking about here at la villa vegas
mobile home park neighbors say they
didn't hear any gunfire but they seemed
to be a lot of commotion on this end of
the park according to metro a white man
in his late 20's was shot and taken to
the hospital where he later died it's
unknown how many times he was shot or
the relationship he had with the suspect
but metro says they weren't alone as
there was a large gathering inside of
the trailer
what we do know is there was a group of
people that were hanging out inside of a
trailer behind me at some point there
was a male who was a white male in his
late 30s who was in possession of a
rifle at some point that male
is believed to have fired a round
striking and killing the victim
now it's unclear the circumstances that
led up to the incident but two people
took off after the man was shot the
suspect and one other person the suspect
is currently on the run as for the other
people inside of the trailer they are
currently being investigated by metro of
course if you know anything you're urged
to contact metro immediately you can
also call crime stoppers to remain
anonymous this is an ongoing
investigation so we will make sure to
keep you posted on air and online about
this story so keep it here on 8 news now
reporting live madison kimbrough back to
you